meine Damen und Herren hören Sie eine
Ansprache des klicksu Moderators
Christoph
krachten unsere nächsten Gäste führen
mich ausgerechnet in den Getränkemarkt
meines
Vertrauens warum nur ah ein Hinweis auf
unsere nächsten Gäste wobei hier fehlt
eine
Flasche es müssten eigentlich vier
Fantas sein denn das ist unser kleines
Bilderrätsel die Fanta vi kommen zu
Klick ihr könnt wieder Fragen stellen am
besten als Videoantwort hochladen wobei
das gibt's ja so nicht mehr der Button
man sucht ihn vergeblich Kommentar
posten und Video anhängen so geht das
inzwischen und wir versuchen auch hier
das müsste aber gehen hier so ein Link
ins Video zu packen und ansonsten gibt
es ein kleines Appetithäppchen von den
Fanta vi ein Blick hinter die Kulissen
der Produktion ihres neuen Albums viel
Spaß